alors que faites vous là au procès
oui tout à fait des achats vont partir à
la destruction et au retraitement et qui
surtout vent permet de redonner un cadre
de vie serein la ville du robert alors
vous procéder régulièrement à ce genre
de procédure
la priorité c'est vraiment la lutte
contre le gâchis oui tout à fait donc on
essaie dans le maximum mais là c'est
facile parce que le véhicule n'est pas
identifiable mais quand le véhicule est
identifiable
on a tous une procédure en avant avant
de pouvoir le retirer alors quand on est
comme ça dans des cités le majorque des
logements sociaux commencent à se faire
comment vous faites pour pouvoir dire
alors oui on est peut-être sur le
domaine privé mais du moment que la
laïcité n'est pas fermée n'est pas
hermétique
le code de la route s'ils appliquent et
à partir du moment où le code de la
route s'ils appliquent on peut
intervenir
[Applaudissements]